marc urbain proulx est professeur
d'économie à l'université du québec à
chicoutimi spécialiste du développement
économique régional
je prie bonsoir bonsoir je fus lyon
alors depuis deux jours françois legault
et pierre feugier bonne se montre très
prudent bout beaucoup plus prudent que
ce qu'on avait entendu jusqu'à
maintenant sur l'avenir de ce projet
sans voix quoi comme signal selon vous
bien ça envoie un signal qu'en fait ils
prennent contre de ce qui s'est passé
depuis trois semaines un élément de
turbulence important dans un dossier
très complexe dans lequel il va y avoir
d'autres éléments de turbulences au
cours des prochains mois des prochaines
dix prochaines années
alors vous voyez monsieur fillion nous
sommes nous sommes en transition
énergétique et on sait pas trop comment
elle va se faire cette transition ne
sais pas quel rythme se faire certains
voudraient qu'elle se fasse pas d'autres
voudraient qu'elle se fasse très très
très rapidement elle va se faire quelque
part entre les deux
et non le sait pas quel rythme une chose
qui est certaine c'est qu'on a besoin de
beaucoup d'énergie sur cette planète
nous consommons beaucoup d'énergie et on
veut se débarrasser du pétrole et puis
et puis du charbon et éventuellement du
gaz alors il vous faut trouver d'autres
types d'énergie qui ne sont pas
disponibles à ce moment ci encore en
2020 seront pas disponibles a coûté que
nous avons besoin et dans cette optique
là avec ce que vous décrivez ce projet
s'inscrit là dedans
en tout cas c'est la rhétorique derrière
ce projet là mais le financement n'est
pas du tout bouclé on parle quand même
de 14 milliards
est ce que le contexte social politique
pourrait refroidir les investisseurs
il est possible ce soir foisy monsieur
fignon c'est bien évident le ministre le
nom ne parlais tout à l'heure et il est
possible que des dégrés il va voir aussi
dodo type de réchauffement on est dans
un contexte où la demande de gaz naturel
est énorme on le voudrait on voudrait
s'en débarrasser aussi du gaz naturel
mais la demande est très forte justement
pour remplacer le pétrole et le charbon
et puis les investisseurs bien sûr ils
vont peut-être d'être faux départ gnl
mais ils vont ils vont te réchauffer par
par d'autres projets sur la planète peut
être qu'ils vont revenir aussi à gnl 10
quelques jours avec des conditions un
peu meilleur on le sait que actuellement
l'une des l'un des freins c'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis trois semaines avec
les revendications autochtones au canada
mais aussi qu'au québec les
revendications sont moins forts on a
depuis 50 ans au québec [ __ ] négocier
concilier avec l'écrit avec les unes ou
et chez période pour des projets
hydroélectriques on a une habitude
négocier 230 généralement assez bien
avec des autochtones
alors il est possible d'aller dans ce
que si le conseil d éduquer mais de
wemotaci disent que la phase est content
il ya peut-être des opportunités août
aussi autour de cela notamment avec la
biomasse le long du parcours de 7,2 de
ses biens aux jo qui va passer au québec
il ya de la production de biomasse était
possible pour justement alimenter le le
fameux tuyaux le fameux gaz odieux qui
va passer peut-être que les autochtones
vont être intéressés par ce type de du
sinn qui va fabriquer de l'énergie à
partir de la biomasse
on verra il va se passer beaucoup de
choses une chose qui est certaine c'est
que pour l'instant nous sommes dans la
faisabilité de ce projet lors il se peut
qu'ils ne se réalisent pas mais si ce
projet ne se réalise pas beaucoup
d'autres ne pourront être réalisés aussi
parce que ça fait partie de deux je
dirais des projets qui ont des impacts
sur l'environnement mais y en a beaucoup
d'autres notamment dans le nord du
québec avec les mène avec des doutes des
projets hydroélectriques et au tabac il
est de plus en plus difficile de faire
ce type de projet liés de plus en plus
difficile les bills et évidemment parce
que l'acceptabilité sociale n'est pas
simple alors il va votre d'édition que
devront se prendre et je pense que le
bape qui valut au saguenay par exemple
et les études qui sont faits sur la
faisabilité de ce projet là sont
excellentes pourquoi ça permet à la
population d'être enseignée et de se
faire une tête à propos du type de
projet l'on parle de l'énergie mais dans
d'autres secteurs d'activité le plein
d'autres
la planète doit faire un virage à le
virage énergétique le virage club ou
lutter contre les changements
climatiques et ottawa
ce virage environnemental eau ne sera
pas simple mais il devra se faire avec
des études de faisabilité et dans la
démocratie est trouvé
les meilleures solutions pour affronter
l'avenir il y avait des économistes qui
disait l'automne dernier une quarantaine
d'économistes qui disait pas certain que
ce projet-là de développer des énergies
fossiles soit le bon projet à développer
il est possible que je respecte ça mais
j'ai des amis à travers ses économistes
la cd collègues à moi mais ils n'ont pas
regardé la demande mondiale je le redis
la demande mondiale est très forte de
gaz naturel actuellement
et puis et puis si c'est le projet gênée
elle se fait pas de doute mieux à faire
ailleurs pour fournir cette demande lors
maintenant on peut dire non gnl bien sûr
on peut dire non à d'autres projets il
ya des conséquences reliées à cela
est-ce que ce projet et d'autres projets
d'ailleurs sont absolument nécessaires
pour la survie des régions écoutez oui
non pas pour la survie comme tel
événement la grille région si on a
besoin de grands projets l'économie
régionale
que ce soit en gaspésie où que ce soit
en abitibi où que ce soit sur la cour
tort au saguenay-lac-saint-jean scellé
pour les grands projets qui sont le
moteur de l'économie
nous avons besoin de cela mais sûrement
de plus on va réussir à survivre quand
même on va continuer de perdre la
population évidemment c'est la pérennité
de nos institutions qu'on a mis en place
depuis 50 ans aussi que moins de
questionner nos collègues nos écoles
secondaires nos hôpitaux est justement
on va survivre à cela je pense que les
la population est capable de de ceux de
se re positionner vis-à-vis des
changements majeurs
alors l'avenir nous le dirons quelles
vont être les chouettes fait par la
société québécoise et des régions merci
pour cette analyse et ses réflexions ce
soir marque urbains pau merci bien au
plaisir